Jennifer Garner and dazzled in a silky
top and black slacks at the series
premiere of her new show
camping debuting October 14th on HBO et
spoke with the actress about getting
into character and her former alias
co-star turned a stars born director
Bradley Cooper so listen the cast so far
has told me about the coffee cake the
pies the homemade honey that you
harvested from your own bees just
harvested it yeah what is this like is
this a are we having a pots and pans
line next I love this jam we're
definitely not having pots and pans line
that I know of but we were cozy on set
weren't we I think maybe also my
character was so mean that I had some
making up to do that's the thing
Jennifer Garner seems nice
Kathryn seems get to that point with her
how did I get to the point of playing
someone who's so not not likable and
you're America's Sweetheart I follow you
on an Instagram - to Tuesday you know
what I mean like this is not you're not
like this character no I'm definitely I
try my best in real life not to be like
this character but I did have a lot of
love for her and I did really understand
where she was coming from and I did see
that at one point in time she was if not
the life of the party the organizer of
the party and she's had a lot of
physical issues since then and it's just
kind of hardened her heart to be
organized we have a surprise for you
we've recently gone into the et vault
and aeleus flashback look at this look
do you know Bradley Cooper look how cute
he is
so cute look at his blonde tipped hair
look he could see he can really sell
something
Bradley Cooper with a sweetie had a
chance to see a star Osborne's not
earlier cut I'm so excited for him I'm
so proud of him
and it's all we could have told you then
that he would that he would do what he's
doing now just like this guy are you the
next I hope to be
[Music]